STEVE: GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME
TO THE NEXT REVOLUTION BUT I'M
STEVE HILTON AND THIS IS THE
HOME OF POSITIVE POPULISM, PRO-
AMERICA, PROFAMILY AND PRO-
AMERICA.
LOOK AT WHAT WE SEE IN THE PAST
FEW WEEKS.
AGE 13 IS SHOT AND KILLED IN
CHICAGO, MCKAY O'BRIEN, 816 SHOT
AND KILLED IN COLUMBUS, OHIO,
ANTHONY THOMPSON, 17, SHOT AND
KILLED IN KNOXVILLE, TENNESSEE.
THESE TERRIBLE STORIES HAVE BEEN
USED AS FODDER FOR THE ONLY
DEBATE THE LEFT SEEMS TO WANT
THESE DAYS, ABOUT RACE.
WE NEED TO STOP AND THINK ABOUT
WHAT WE ARE REALLY SEEN.
THERE IS NO CONCEIVABLE REASON
FOR A 13 -YEAR-OLD TO BE
WANDERING THE STREETS AT
2:40 A.M. WITH A GUN OR FOR A 16
-YEAR-OLD TO BE SCREAMING AND
FIGHTING IN BROAD DAYLIGHT ARMED
WITH A KNIFE AND A 17 -YEAR-OLD
TO HIDE A GUN IN HIS HOODIE AT
SCHOOL AND NONE OF THIS IS A
PERFECT PARENT IN A POSITION TO
JUDGE BUT LIFE IS TOUGH FOR MANY
PEOPLE.
BUT THERE IS SOMETHING GOING
TERRIBLY WRONG IN AMERICA AND
IT'S SO DEEP AND SO PERSONAL AND
MAKES MANY PEOPLE SO
UNCOMFORTABLE THAT WE IGNORE IT
AND IT'S NOT GOING AWAY AND THE
PROBLEM IS GETTING WORSE.
THE PROBLEM THAT CRISIS IS THE
COLLAPSE OF FAMILY IN AMERICA.
YOU SEE IT IN THE STORIES AND
YOU SEE IT IN THE NUMBERS, WHERE
WE ONCE TALKED ABOUT DIVORCE AND
FAMILY BREAKUP BUT TODAY
FAMILIES ARE NOT EVEN BEING
FORMED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
OUR MARRIAGE RATE IS AT THE
LOWEST EVER RECORDED.
NEARLY A QUARTER OF AMERICAN
CHILDREN LIVE WITH ONE PARENT
AND NO OTHER ADULTS.
MORE THAN THREE TIMES THE RATE
AND THE REST OF THE WORLD.
IN 201940% OF CHILDREN WERE BORN
OUTSIDE MARRIAGE.
NEARLY HALF A MILLION AMERICAN
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE WITHOUT
EITHER PARENT, HALF A MILLION
AND YOU SEE THE CONSEQUENCES ALL
AROUND US, NOT JUST THOSE IN
GANGS OR MIXED UP IN CRIME AND
DISORDER BUT IN EVERY DAY,
EVERYWHERE COLLAPSE OF CIVILIZED
AGGRESSIVE, RUDE, DISRESPECTED
THIS DISC BEHAVIOR AND KIDS
ADDICTED TO SCREENS AND CAPABLE
OF FORMING HEALTHY HUMAN
RELATIONSHIPS.
IT'S A DISASTER.
IT'S AN ECONOMIC DISASTER
BECAUSE WE NOTE THAT A STABLE
FAMILY MAKES A HUGE DIFFERENCE
FOR LIFE CHANCES AND
OPPORTUNITIES.
IF YOU'RE BORN IN THE BOTTOM 20%
OF THE INCOME SCALE YOUR CHANCES
OF REACHING THE TOP 20% ARE FOUR
TIMES HIGHER IF YOUR PARENTS
STAYED MARRIED.
YOUR CHANCES OF STAYING IN THE
BOTTOM 20% IF YOUR PARENTS NEVER
MARRY IS 50/50 BUT IF YOU
PARENTS ARE MARRIED AND DROPPED
TO JUST 70%.
MARRIAGE MAKES A MASSIVE
DIFFERENCE IN KEEPING FAMILIES
STABLE.
ON AVERAGE, IF PARENTS ARE
MARRIED THREE QUARTERS ARE STILL
TOGETHER BY THE TIME THE CHILD
IS 12 BUT IF THEY ARE JUST
LIVING TOGETHER IT'S ONLY A
QUARTER.
THE NORMALIZATION OF BROKEN
FAMILIES IS A SOCIAL DISASTER TO
BECAUSE SUBSTANCE ABUSE, MENTAL
ILLNESS AND CRIME ARE ALL MORE
COMMON IN DISRUPTED FAMILIES.
THIS IS NOT MORALIZING BUT IT IS
THE FACTS AND THE DATA AND
REMEMBER HOW WE ARE TOLD TO
FOLLOW THAT?
NOT WHEN IT COMES TO THE ISSUE
OF FAMILY, IT SEEMS.
NO ONE WANTS TO TALK ABOUT IT
BECAUSE FAMILY BREAKDOWN AND
FAMILIES NOT BEING FORMED IN THE
FIRST PLACE IS SO WIDESPREAD
THAT PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO SEEM
JUDGMENTAL BUT ACTUALLY THE
LIBERAL ELITE ARE JUDGMENTAL AND
THEY LOOK DOWN THEIR NOSES AT
THE PRIORITIZATION OF STABLE
FAMILIES.
EVEN IF IT COMES FROM OBAMA WHEN
HE DARED TALK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF STRONG FAMILIES HE
WAS SLAMMED BY THE LEFT.
OF COURSE, NOT EVERY CHILD OF
MARRIED PARENTS IS GUARANTEED A
PERFECT LIFE BUT WE HAVE SHOWN
YOU THE FACTS THAT MARRIED IS
STATISTICALLY BETTER FOR
CHILDREN, BETTER FOR SOCIETY
THAN THE ALTERNATIVE.
A LOT BETTER.
FOR DECADES THE ESTABLISHED AND
HIS PUT POLICIES IN THE TAX AND
WELFARE SYSTEMS THAT UNDERMINE
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY STABILITY
AND BIDEN'S RECENT BAILOUT BILL
MORE THAN DOUBLED PAYMENTS TO
SINGLE PARENTS AND THE ELITE
REJECT ALL THIS BY SAYING IT'S
CRAZY TO ARGUE THAT PEOPLE MAKE
THESE DECISIONS BASED ON
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES BUT IF
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES MAKE NO
DIFFERENCE WHY DO THEY WANT
SUBSIDIES FOR ELECTRIC CARS OR
SOLAR PANELS OR THAT ALL THE
OTHER THINGS THEY WANT MORE OF?
WELL, IF YOU CARE ABOUT POVERTY,
INEQUALITY, SOCIAL MOBILITY,
CRIME, SUBSTANCE ABUSE, MENTAL
HEALTH AS WE HAVE COME
HANDSOMELY ESTABLISHED WITH THE
DATA YOU SHOULD WANT TO SEE MORE
STABLE FAMILIES WHICH MEANS MORE
MARRIAGE AND SO LET'S
INCENTIVIZE THAT FOR GOODNESS
SAKE.
IS THERE ANY MORE DESERVING OF
SUBSIDIES?
AS WITH SO MANY THINGS WITH THE
ASTONISHMENT THEIR FURIOUS
OPPOSITION TO POLICIES THAT
PROMOTE FAMILY STABILITY.
IF THE MOST IN NORMA'S HYPOCRISY
BECAUSE THERE IS ONE PART OF OUR
SOCIETY WHERE FAMILY STABILITY
IS GOING UP, NOT DOWN AND
MARRIAGE RATES ARE INCREASING
NOT FALLING AND YET, AMONG THE
RICH AND EDUCATED AND IN FACT
THERE'S ANOTHER PLACE MARRIAGE
IS INCREASING AND GAY AND
LESBIAN AMERICANS ARE GETTING
MARRIED AND I THINK THAT'S
GREAT.
IT'S A VOTE OF CONFIDENCE IN ONE
OF THE INSTITUTIONS
CONSERVATIVES MOST CHERISH AND
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN FOR MARRIAGE
EQUALITY AND I BELIEVE IN
MARRIAGE EQUALITY SO MUCH I EVEN
THINK STRAIGHT PEOPLE SHOULD GET
MARRIED IF THEY WANT TO RAISE A
FAMILY.
THE MARRIAGE PROBLEM IN AMERICA
IS NOT THAT GAY PEOPLE AREN'T
GETTING MARRIED BUT BECAUSE
STRAIGHT PEOPLE AREN'T.
WE MUST REBUILD THE AMERICAN
FAMILY AND THAT STARTS WITH
MARRIAGE.
RAISING A FAMILY IS HARD OR AS
TIM SCOTT SAID THIS WEEK PARENTS
DO A HEROIC JOB BUT IT'S NOT A
-┘- IT IS BETTER FOR A CHILD TO
BE RAISED BY TWO PARENTS NOT
ONE.
THE FIRST WE MUST END THE
INSANITY OF INCENTIVIZING SINGLE
PARENTHOOD.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE A NUMBER OF
REPUBLICAN SENATORS WORKING ON
PLANS TO DO JUST THAT IN ONE OF
THEM MARSHA BLACKBURN WILL BE
HERE TONIGHT.
THEN WE MUST POSITIVELY
ENCOURAGE MARRIAGE LIKE THEY DO
IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
IN ISRAEL CERTAIN TAX CREDITS
ARE ONLY AVAILABLE TO ADULTS WHO
ARE MARRIED.
IN JAPAN COUPLES CAN GET OVER
$5000 FOR GETTING MARRIED AND IN
HUNGARY WHICH IS RECENTLY BECOME
A WORLD LEADER IN PROFAMILY
POLICY, NEW COUPLES CAN GET
SUBSIDIZED LOANS WHICH ARE
COMPLETELY FORGIVEN IF THEY HAVE
THREE CHILDREN TOGETHER.
AND HERE SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY HAS
A PARENTS TAX CREDIT PLAN WHICH
GIVES MARRIED COUPLES AN EXTRA
$6000 A YEAR.
IT WILL TAKE MORE THAN FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES TO REBUILD THE
AMERICAN FAMILY.
ONE OF THE REASONS MARRIAGE
RATES HAVE COLLAPSED IN
WORKING-CLASS COMMUNITIES IS THE
DESTRUCTION OF STEADY JOBS FOR
MEN.
WE NEED TO STOP THE COLLEGE FOR
ALL ELITISM AND GIVEN ANOTHER
DISASTROUS PUSH BY BIDEN THIS
WEEK AND DIVERT, MUCH OF THE
MONEY WE CURRENTLY PUT INTO
HIGHER EDUCATION INTO SKILLS
BASED VOCATIONAL TRAINING AND
BOOSTING THAT WITH A HUGE UNTOLD
SUCCESS STORY OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, BY THE WAY, AN
EFFORT LED BY A BUNKER TRUMP WAS
ALSO BEHIND THE MOST PROFAMILY
MOVEMENT BY ANY ADMINISTRATION
IN DECADES.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
EXPANSION OF FAMILY LEAVE.
THAT IS SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT STRESSFUL
TIMES LIKE HAVING A NEWBORN IN
THE HOUSE OR WHEN MOST BREAKUPS
HAPPEN IN FAMILY RELATIONSHIPS,
PARENTING IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING WE EVER DO AND IT'S
RIDICULOUS THAT THEY ARE SO
LITTLE HELP AND IT DOESN'T NEED
TO BE THE NANNY STATE, LOCAL
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS, FAITH
GROUPS, THEY CAN PLAY A MUCH
BIGGER ROLE AND DEMOCRATS WANT
GOVERNMENT TO PLAY A MUCH BIGGER
ROLE.
JUST LISTEN TO THIS.
THIS IS FROM BIDEN'S DOMESTIC
POLICY CHIEF SUSAN RICE LAST
WEEK.
QUOTE, WE WANT PARENTS TO BE IN
THE WORKFORCE, ESPECIALLY
MOTHERS.
DO YOU, SUSAN RICE?
WHO MADE YOU THE BOSS OF EVERY
MOTHER IN AMERICA?
ACCORDING TO RECENT RESEARCH
MOST MOTHERS ACTUALLY DON'T WANT
TO BE IN FULL-TIME WORK.
THEY WOULD RATHER BE FULL-TIME
PARENTS OR DOING PART-TIME WORK
AND THE POINT IS IT SHOULD BE
THEIR CHOICE, NOT SUSAN RICE'S
CHOICE.
RAISING KIDS IS CONTRIBUTING TO
THE ECONOMY AND THAT THE MOST
IMPORTANT WORK ANYONE CAN DO.
WE SHOULD REWARDED, NOT PUNISH
IT AND WE ARE TRYING TO MAKE
PARENTS WHO STAY AT HOME
SECOND-CLASS CITIZENS AND NO, IT
DOESN'T MEAN WOMEN IN THE
KITCHEN AND MEN AS BREADWINNERS
BUT A THIRD OF WISE OUT EARN
THEIR HUSBANDS.
EACH FAMILY IS DIFFERENT AND
THEY SHOULD DECIDE BUT THE
DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT PARENTS TO
DECIDE AND THEY WANT NATURALIZED
CHILDCARE AND ALL PARENTS AND
ALL STAFF CAN WORK WITH
GOVERNMENT HANDOUTS TO PAY
SOMEONE ELSE TO LOOK AFTER THEIR
CHILDREN.
THE PLAN BIDEN JUST ANNOUNCED IS
TRIED IN CANADA AND THIS WAS THE
RESULT ACCORDING TO -┘- KIDS WEE
WORSE OFF SO WE MUST FIGHT THE
NIGHTMARE OF THE LESS
INDUSTRIALIZED FACTORIES
CHILDCARE.
THERE IS A MORE CONSERVATIVE WAY
IN A MORE HUMAN WAY TO HELP
FAMILIES.
COMMUNITY BASED, MARRIAGE AND
PARENT COACHING, NURSE FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP'S WERE A NURSE
VISITS A FAMILIES HOME REGULARLY
TO HELP MAKE SURE EVERYTHING IS
ON TRACK.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT EVERYTHING IN
THIS WAY.
DOES THAT SUPPORT OR UNDERMINE
FAMILIES?
PEOPLE ARE PICKING UP TO THE
WOKE INDOCTRINATION GOING ON IN
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
BUT FOR EVEN LONGER THERE'S BEEN
AN ANTIFAMILY BIAS IN THE SYSTEM
AND A MORAL ECOLOGY WHICH
DEVALUES STABLE FAMILIES.
YOU DON'T SEE THAT SO MUCH AND
INDEPENDENT SCHOOLS OR THOSE ONE
BY FAITH ORGANIZATIONS.
IT'S ANOTHER REASON TO END THE
PUBLIC A SCHOOL MONOPOLY AND PUT
POWER IN THE PARENTS HANDS.
THESE ARE ALL PART OF WHAT THE
BROOKINGS INSTITUTION CALLS THE
SUCCESS SEQUENCE FOR STABLE
FAMILIES.
GETTING AT LEAST A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA, WORKING AND THEN
MARRYING BEFORE HAVING CHILDREN.
RESEARCH BY SOCIOLOGISTS BRAD
WILCOX AND WENDY WANG SHOWED
THAT ONLY 3% OF MILLENNIAL'S WHO
DID THESE THREE THINGS ARE IN
POVERTY BY THE TIME THEY REACH
ADULT HOOD.
WE CAN TEACH THIS, PROMOTE THIS,
BUT MANY FIND THIS MESSAGE.
FINISH HIGH SCHOOL, GET A JOB,
GET MARRIED.
FAMILY, PARENTING THE WAY WE
RAISE OUR KIDS IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE FACING AMERICA
AND WE BARELY TALK ABOUT IT.
ON THE SHOW WE WILL TALK ABOUT
IT.
WE WILL FIG